welcome back everybody to the David
Pac-Man show former Republican
Congressman will Hurd is joining the
ranks of Republicans jumping into this
2024 presidential primary it is getting
very very full uh will heard like I said
it was a congressman and he also worked
in the CIA and he's kind of known as a
more moderate Republican and he is more
moderate he's criticized Trump it's
another example though of someone who I
don't really understand how he fits into
the picture how he would win a
Republican primary with how Maga the GOP
is right now
um but here's this from CNN former Texas
representative will Hurd launches 2024
bid for GOP Presidential nomination
former Texas uh representative will hurt
on Thursday launched a bid for the 2024
Republican Presidential nomination
joining a crowded field looking to
challenge front runner foreign president
Donald
Trump will look at uh him talking about
why he announced in just a moment but
continuing herd has been outspoken and
his criticism of trump following the
former president's indictment on federal
charges over his alleged mishandling of
classified documents Trump has pleaded
not guilty to all charges and then
interestingly it lists everyone in the
race right now in case you've forgotten
you have DeSantis you have Mike Pence
you have Tim Scott you have Nikki Haley
you have ASA Hutchinson Chris Christie
Doug burgum
uh vivekama Swami Francis Juarez and
Larry Elder and now will Hurd so with
that being said uh here's this from CBS
mornings where he's making this
announcement I want to let everybody
know that this morning uh my file to be
the Republican nominee for president of
the United States this is a a decision
that my wife and I decided to do because
we live in complicated times and we need
Common Sense there are a number of
generational defining challenges that
we're faced with in the United States of
America everything from the Chinese
government trying to surpass us as the
global superpower the fact that
inflation is persistent at a time when
Technologies like artificial
intelligence is going to upend every
single industry and our kids or their
their scores and math science and
reading are the lowest they've ever been
in this Century these are the issues we
should be talking about and to be frank
I'm pissed that we're not talking about
these things I'm pissed that our elected
official are telling us to to hate our
neighbors right our neighbors are not
our enemies they're our fellow Americans
who we just happen to have a
disagreement with these are the issues
that that we should be talking about and
I believe the Republican Party can be
the party that talks about the future
not the past we should be putting out a
vision of how do we have unprecedented
peace how do we have a thriving economy
how do we make sure our kids have a
world-class education regardless of
their well stop it there but uh
you know it's interesting I have a
former Republican friend who
still a friend former Republican to be
clear and he's constantly emailing me
different people he thinks could be a
good presidential option
um and he's like obviously I know you
differ with this person because I'm not
a Republican and any conservative I'm
going to disagree with severely but
would send me more respectable options
do you think they would have a chance
would they have a chance would they have
a chance in this Republican primary and
I've had to explain multiple times
unfortunately
even though there are a lot of people
that I disagree with a lot but wish
would be more prominent within the GOP
so that we could have a more healthy
vibrant political discussion
unfortunately this current GOP base at
least there are moderate Republicans
that still exist but the base that's the
engine that drives the agenda is so
extreme it's so Maga that the only
person who really had a shot of
defeating Trump was someone like
DeSantis who was trying to be a little
Trump 2.0 and failing miserably
apparently
um and it is yes terrifying it's so
unfortunate but that's the reality and
so all these people who are jumping in
someone like Chris Christie that we
talked about earlier or will Hurd who
um would be far better than Trump
they're not going to have a shot because
of that fact because they are more
reasonable than Trump and that's just
not what's selling right now within the
mag Republican party base